good evening members
good evening everybody
welcome to the audit committee
i've got to do the emergency evacuation
announcement first
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the room
via the same door you came in
turn right and out of the main doors
into the car park which is the assembly
point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please switch off mobile phones or turn
them to silent
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded
members when i invite you to speak
please ensure you have one of the
microphones in front of you before
speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing loop and for the audio recording
these are not all these are switched on
already for you to speak so you do not
need to adjust them
please make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for for
then against
any recommendations those abstaining
from voting will be noted by officers
agenda item one
apologies for absence
we've received apologies from councillor
andrew cross
are there any other apologies members
are you are you certain can you please
indicate
if not
you're okay you can hear me
of course
appreciate it
agenda item 2 substitute members
councillor david sharp welcome you're
substituting for councillor andrew cross
agenda item three
non-members attending
welcome councillor mrs mason
agenda item 4
minutes of the meeting held on the 15th
of march 2022
are these minutes agreed members
agenda item five to receive declarations
of interest
members
are there any declarations of interest
agenda item 6
the annual audit report 2020 to 2021
debbie hansen will introduce the report
thank you
conclusion is that okay it seems to be
vibrating
which summarizes the conclusion of our
audit work um it's slightly different
than in previous years when we would
have brought you something called the
annual audit letter and that would have
summarized the work on the opinion and
also the value for money conclusion and
this report does the same but what the
members of the committee will not have
seen before is the conclusion of our
work on value for money that used to
previously be reported in our what we
called our auditor's results reports um
just confused anagrams
um but due to changes in the nao code
there's maybe more of a separation
between the work on the financial
statements and the work we do on value
for money so our value for money work is
now reported purely through this report
that you're receiving today
so hopefully that just gives some
background to members
what i'd like to do is just take you
through the executive summary very
briefly and then just refer you to the
section on value for money because as i
said that's the bit that's really new
the other bits you will have seen before
so in terms of the financial statements
and the executive summary starts on page
eight if you're using electronic pack
it will be page three if you're using
the hard copy pack of our papers
in terms of financial statements we
issued an unqualified opinion on the
financial statements on the 10th of
february this year
we also concluded that the use of the
going concern approach in preparing the
financial statements was appropriate
and we also concluded that the financial
information and statements of accounts
was consistent with the audited accounts
um we also didn't have any matters to
report by exception in relation to value
for money therefore you had a completely
unclean and unmodified audit report
and we were also happy that the annual
governance statement had adequately
reflected the arrangements the council
had in place and we didn't identify any
issues that required us to do any sort
of public reporting
we also issued our provisional audit
results report in december um before
actually issuing our opinion in february
we considered whether we needed to bring
an updated report back to this committee
but as there were no significant changes
between our provisional audit results
report in our final position we
concluded we didn't need to do that
the one thing we've not yet been able to
do is issue the certificate in relation
to the audit and just to explain the
certificate basically says that we've
discharged all of our responsibilities
under the nao code of audit practice
one of those responsibilities is to
undertake procedures
on the whole of government account
submission that the council prepares on
behalf of the nao
the only reason we haven't been able to
do that is because the nao has not
issued the instructions for auditors yet
in relation to the
2020-21 financial year
um therefore although we fully expect
that rochford will be below the
threshold and not require any work to be
undertaken until those instructions are
issued and confirmed we can't actually
complete that element of our work submit
the assurance return to the nao and
therefore issue a certificate
excuse me i am however aware that the
instructions um have been issued this
week um i think there are still some
issues with those that we need to
resolve but therefore i'm hopeful that
we can issue the certificate very soon
which will be good news and close off
the audit
completely um i think just by way of
context i think you can tell from the
the issues that we've reported in here
that we identified a number of areas of
focus in our work we didn't identify any
issues or problems in any of those areas
and generally the council's accounts are
well prepared and with good support in
working papers and we find very few
errors i think the only issues we found
with some minor disclosure errors in the
account so i think that gives
members of this committee hopefully
assurance over the quality and
robustness of the council's processes
for production of the accounts
if i can then just take you to page 18
again using the electronic numbering of
the report
this is where we start our vfm
commentary
we're required to comment across three
key areas so we come into financial
sustainability
governance and then the council's
arrangements of improving economy
efficiency and effectiveness
we've included quite a lot of commentary
on each of those areas this year because
this is year one of the new code and
therefore the first year we've reported
under these more detailed requirements
i think we'd just like to draw out that
in relation to financial sustainable
sustainability kobe's obviously
continued to impact on the councils as
all local authorities have been impacted
the council has continued to update its
mtfs and to reflect the impact of cobit
and other pressures
and does highlight a gap of around 2
million in terms of the budget by
2015-16
therefore we have drawn
attention to the fact that it's
important that the council continues to
drive its transformation agenda um but
we do know that the council's had a good
track record of delivering savings in
the past but it is important that you
keep your focus on that transformation
agenda and continuing to make savings
going forwards
and we also noted there's some part and
greater development of partnerships that
the council is undertaking again both to
improve services but also to achieve
efficiencies and savings and we also
know the general fund balance is
maintained at a level of 10
of the net budget to ensure there's a
sufficient contingency within that
budget
in relation to governance again we've um
noted a number of arrangements there so
the council has robust risk management
arrangements in place it also has
performance monitoring systems where you
monitor kpis etc and also business
business plans are produced for key
areas
finally in relation to arrangements for
economy efficiency effectiveness the
council regularly monitors its kpis
also has as i said it's transformation
programme which is obviously focused on
economy efficiency and effectiveness
and also it has an investor save
programme and so i think we've drawn all
of those things out as positive areas
that we've noted in our value for money
work
and as i said we've got no issues or
concerns to report but we have included
more detailed commentary on the
arrangements that the council has in
place
i wasn't proposing to say any more about
the report but i'm very happy to take
any questions or any comments on
anything that's within there
no
um i've just got one
you mentioned a date
this two million gap
yes
sorry i didn't get the date sorry it was
by by the end of 2015-16
so your mtfs obviously looks forward
enough
did i say did i do it again
yeah
that was why it would make sense sorry
that's what i thought i heard but yeah
and i actually wrote down 25 26 i just
said 15 16.
thank you i didn't miss here then no
thank you from that thank you
so we have we have no further questions
so
members is the annual report for the
year ended 31st of march 2021 noted
thank you members
agenda item seven
day yeah
i am yeah thank you
sorry thank you
agenda item 7 external auditor report
certification of claims and returns
annual report 20 20 21.
mr mike porter audit and corporate fraud
service manager
will introduce this report thank you
thank you very much chair um not being
an external auditor i will do my best to
take you through the main issues arising
from the report
the report summarizes the main issues
arising from bdo certification of the
housing benefit grant for the financial
year ended 31st march 2021
the grant reimburses the council in
respect of housing benefit paid out to
the value of around 12 million
so in terms of certifying what a
certified involved so certified involves
agreeing the entries in the claim to the
underlying records and testing a sample
of cases from each benefit type to
confirm that benefit has been correctly
awarded in accordance with irrelevant
legislation
the report itself um
highlights two main benefit types we've
got non-hra so this relates to people in
bed and breakfast accommodation or
temporary accommodation
the other allowance that it deals with
is rent allowance and this relates to
private rented accommodation or housing
association
an initial sample testing work is
undertaken by internal audit
and the guidance requires that
additional testing of 40 plus testing is
undertaken where errors identify so
where internal audit identifies errors
in housing benefit payments
additional 40 plus testing is required
this 40 plus testing is undertaken by
the rest and ben servers
further
the results of the the testing are
extrapolated
to determine the potential error amount
and as reported by bdo they've mended
the claim by two thousand ninety seven
pounds so in relation to it a claim of
twelve million pound that's a small
adjustment to the value of the overall
claim
the claim may be amended by a further
nineteen thousand pound if the dwp is
minded to do so so
what bdo have done is basically where
they can test the full sample and
actually come up with a figure for the
adjustment of the claim they will amend
the claim but well they have to
extrapolate because we can't test the
whole population because otherwise we'd
be there all year
so basically they do an extrapolation
process whereby they say if that error
level continues in the population as a
whole this is likely to be the error
rate so they could adjust the claim by a
further 19 000 pound but that's not
something that normally happens because
they can't
substantiate that figure so it's a best
guess so if that error rate continues in
the population if we continue testing
this is likely to be the error rate but
the claim is not normally amended by
that figure so they only amend the claim
where they've tested the whole
population all the all the claimants
so the claim is only going to be amended
by uh 2097 pound so i think that's a
good news story for us in terms of the
um 12 million claim so i'm quite happy
to try and answer any questions
members do you have any questions
counselor sharp
uh you may ask um
how long ernst young have been the
external auditor
and uh have they ever been tested on a
competitive basis for their fees which
are going up quite substantially
in relation to this um
ernst and young are not the external
order that's a bdi bdo
and they were subject to
a procurement exercise which we did
about three years ago right so we market
tested by
yeah inviting i think five five firms to
bid for the work
and they were selected on cost
price
ratio fine thank you
questions
no
so is the certification of claims and
returns annual report 2021 noted
thank you members
agenda item 8
internal audit annual report 2021-22
mr mike porter will introduce this
report
the report provides details of the work
carried out by the internal audit team
for 2021-22
and also includes the chief audit
executive's annual audit opinion that
also
is included in the ags
the accounts and audit regulations 2015
require the council to to undertake an
effective program of internal audit
activity
to evaluate the effectiveness of the
council's risk management control and
governance processes
taking into account relevant public
sector internal auditing standards
so in i'll start with the the
opinion which is provided at 4.9
officials report
so based based on the work performed
during the course of the year and other
sources of assurance i'm of the opinion
that adequate assurance can be taken
that the council's risk management
internal control and governance
processes in operation during the year
to 31st march 22
generally recalled with proper practice
and are fundamentally sound although
there are opportunities to improve
arrangements to enhance the government's
framework
i mean
we use the word adequate so you can take
the word adequate to be good um
you don't get
essentially a substantial opinion so you
know adequate it's good it's basically
the sound
the controls are working well
we may
you know you might get a limited opinion
but that's not the case in this case but
you you're very unlikely to get a
substantial
or opinion adequate is good adequate is
a good opinion so it basically says in
essence we have a it's a positive result
and
and provides confirmation that overall
the controls and processes that have
been
continued to work during the course of
the year so it's a good is a good
opinion
so how did we arrive at that opinion
the opinion is derived from the work of
the team carried out during the course
of the year and this is the highlighted
appendix one from other sources of
reassurance
the audit plan was completed in full
a summer of the results is provided at
section 3.2
in summary we completed 25 audit
engagements
5 have been assessed as good
12 as adequate and two is limited
with two with a positive direction of
travel
and two where the nature of the
engagement
did not facilitate any opinion and we in
addition to that we also undertook two
grant certifications
in relation to our work the majority of
our work involves examination of
controls or identification of the lack
of controls
and and through agreed recommendations
we seek to address the control
weaknesses
implementation of audit recommendations
by service management has been good to
date
10 recommendations were brought forward
into the into 21-22 and during the year
we raised a further 35 new
recommendations
there are only 31 recommendations sorry
there are 14 recommendations that have
been carried forward into the new
financial year we've implemented 31
recommendations in total during the
course of the year
lastly i'd like to touch briefly on
fraud
the council's arrangements for combating
fraud are effective
and operating well
in relation to cashable savings
identified by the council we have
identified 591 000 pounds worth of
cashable savings identified in relation
to fraud work and these are in the areas
of council tax business rates and
housing benefit
work is underway to develop an
up-to-date counter fraud strategy
as part of this process a fraud risk
register is being completed
this is an early stage work is also been
undertaken to update the council's
anti-money money laundering procedures
as well
although not mentioned in my report for
the year other noteworthy messages
include the transfer of
rochester's internal audit service
that's also recently been discussed at
committee to baseline the council so
basically council now provides the
internal audit service for rochard
one one of the existing members of staff
that becky has transferred over to basil
and council while jim who's been a long
standing employee the council decided to
retire
i'm quite happy to take any questions in
relation to my report
no
members
the recommendation is that the chief
audit executive's opinion on the overall
adequacy and effectiveness of the
council systems of governance risk
management and internal control be noted
that noted members
thank you members
gender item 9
draft annual governance statement for 20
21 22.
um
naomi lucas you'll be uh presenting this
yes
yes thank you
thank you members so um yeah members of
the committee will be aware that um in
compliance with the accounts and audit
regulations that an annual government
governance statement must be prepared
and presented to members each year for
their consideration
and this must be endorsed by the audit
committee prior to its certification by
the leader of the council and the chief
executive and it's published alongside
the council statement of accounts
so just to give a quick overview of what
the annual governance statement sort of
encompasses um it identifies the key
procedures within the council that
ensure there is effective system of
internal control and effective
governance arrangements upon which you
can place your assurance
it reflects the local code of corporate
governance that we have in place within
the council
and it includes an update on progress
made against any actions and risks
identified in the prior year ags
so it also sets out the broad management
arrangements across the council
how we've obtained the insurance in
terms of governance arrangements and
more generally the policies and
strategies are in place across the
council
in terms of the time frame that the
report covers it it's for the financial
year 2021-22
but it will also cover the period um of
2223 up until the date at which the
accounts are signed off
so it's possible that there may be
further changes between um the date of
consideration tonight and the formal
signing off of the
audited accounts
and in in that case um we would usually
request that um
there's a delegated authority to the
chair of the audit committee to
authorize any changes of a
non-significant nature
um however if there were any more
significant changes that came to light
during that period we would of course
bring that back to the audit committee
for your consideration
um so
i think the actual wages itself should
be reasonably
self-explanatory but i'm happy to try
and answer any
questions
and
yeah there's a number of recommendations
for noting and agreeing at the end of
the report thank you
members are there any questions
no members there are four
recommendations
i will read them out
that the draft annual governance
statement for 2021 22 be noted
that it be noted that the annual
governance statement for 2021 22 will be
reviewed and updated at the time the
draft accounts are audited
three that authorities delegated to the
chair of the audit committee to endorse
non-significant changes to the ags
following review by the council's
external auditors and then referred to
the joint chief executive and leader of
the council for signature
and number four
that any significant changes to the ags
be brought back to audit committee for
review
prior to sign off by the joint chief
executive and leader
are you happy to take these on the block
do we agree with us
and noted
sorry i have to do a vote on this so for
item three and four
can you please raise your hands in favor
you know
thank you may lower your hand that's
unanimous
and
and item number four
okay
so that is unanimous
right item number 10 of the agenda
review of the council's risk register
2022-23
again naomi lucas the assistant director
of resources will introduce the report
um this report um is the um six monthly
review of the council's risk register
and is presented for your consideration
and the last update was provided in
december 2021
um and a number of risks have been
reviewed on a cyclical basis since that
point which are detailed within the
report
so the the complete summary risk
register
is included at appendix one so that sets
out all the corporate risks for the
council
and it also sets out the controls in
place to mitigate those risks and an
assessment of whether the risk is
considered to be higher medium or low
risk
there is further detail that supports
the corporate risk register in the form
of service risk risk registers
and other work that happens in the
background which is available upon
request
so
at the last audit committee
there were a few queries
raised about the risk management process
and we've tried to address some of those
queries that section um sorry paragraph
4.3 of the report
um
so yeah again i think that's reasonably
kind of self-explanatory but if anyone's
got any questions happy to try and
answer those
and at paragraph 4.4 we set out the
actual risks that have been reviewed
since december
and members will see that there's only
really been sort of minor wording
updates to most of the risks the scores
themselves haven't changed
um however that you will note there is
one new corporate risk that's been added
to the register um which is risk 16
and that reflects the one team
transformation projects um
which is the work that we're doing to
create partnership with brentwood
borough council
um so at the moment that new risk has
been deemed to have good controls and is
rated overall as a medium risk given the
early stages of the program but that
will of course be readily monitored and
reviewed as that progresses
section 5 just sets out the risks which
the council deems still to be have a
high level of residual risk after the
controls are in place
and those risks again haven't changed
since the last time it was reported
so it's risk 3b which is health and
safety which i know we've sort of
discussed in detail a number of times at
this committee
um
we have been making active progress in
terms of
some of the control measures in place to
try and mitigate that risk um and we
have we have made further progress
however at this time um the um sort of
health and safety manager still feels
that there is a little bit of
improvement to be made in some areas in
terms of a consistent application across
the council so that's why that risk
remains high
the other two risks which are still
deemed to be high are
about balanced budgets obviously the
financial sustainability of the council
as debbie highlighted earlier in the
value for money opinion of the um
audited accounts so that remains a kind
of obviously a key area or a focus for
the council to make sure we can deliver
that um balanced mtfs position going
forward
and also the ability to recruit and
retain staff and i'm sure members are
aware that not just as a council but
more generally
across the country recruitment and
retention is is a key risk for for a lot
of organizations and that is definitely
the case for us as well so that's why
that risk remains high
at section six there's just a few
emerging issues for members sort of to
know and consider in terms of kind of
future work around this
um and yeah i think that's probably all
i would draw your attention to at this
time but i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you chair
um naomi um i know we discussed this in
the last we've discussed this before uh
risk 3b um on risk nine is there any
i'd have you any timelines when these
will actually
come really removed from risk i can
understand risk 10 because you could
never say when you can retain staff but
um it's a bit concerning with health and
safety and the balanced budget
thank you
yeah thank you councillor shaw so um
as i mentioned in relation to risk 3b so
the health and safety one so obviously
the the score is a combination of the
likelihoods and the impacts so i think
the impacts of that if there was um a
sort of significant health and safety
issue would always be high because
obviously you know some kind of personal
safety in life that's at risk so i think
the impact of a um a serious incident
would always probably be high
so it's about the likelihood of it
occurring um and
obviously the likelihood is not is not
high which is why the overall risk is
not high but i think as i said earlier
there's good practice across the
majority of the organization there's
just a few sort of pockets of um
areas where the health and safety
manager feels there's still some
improvements that could be made and he's
specifically been picking that up and
following that up with those individual
service areas so i know that the new
chief executive for the council is keen
to see that those controls sort of move
from
there too high as well so i think that
is something we're actively working on
and we're hopeful that that that risk or
will come down um over the next few
months so yeah that's all i can really
say on that one moment
um
okay and on the budget one i suppose
similarly that because it's such a kind
of
um
you know significant um area for the
council in terms of the impact of not
setting a balanced budget that the kind
of um impact score is is always probably
going to be high the likelihood um again
is slightly out of our control in terms
of what we can do we're obviously
actively trying to manage our budget all
the time but there is a number of
factors outside of our control um for
example inflationary pressures we're
seeing at the moment but also the
government's funding regime so there's
only a limited amount of sort of control
measures we can put in place to actually
manage that risk which is why that one's
still high as well
thank you very much
um it's just a question i might if i
said the right format um i'm just
interested when you talk about the
recruit recruitment situation does this
council and i don't know does this
council have an internal budget for
recruiting on training so for bringing
people in to train for positions within
this council is that a separate
um
so just to clarify what you mean are you
talking like about apprentices and that
kind of transition
bringing youngsters if you like youth
into the council to pro for
substantial positions
um yeah so i think we're always open to
all kind of avenues of um recruitment
and retention and that sort of
encompasses um a lot of different kind
of roles within the organization and
obviously that it kind of depends on the
needs and the sort of of the particular
team and and and the candidates out
there but certainly we have training
roles within the organization and we've
um within finance team supported
a number of our employees to um sort of
train up and do their accountancy
qualifications for example and then once
we've done that we're obviously keen to
kind of retain those staff
we have had apprentices and i think
we're actively recruiting um a number of
new apprentices at the moment so again
we are looking to sort of grow our own
if you like um as a way of kind of um
bringing um yeah young people and um
sort of talented people on board um
but as a site it has to be sort of part
of a blended recruitment approach in
terms of the the skills that are needed
across the organisation
just got a couple of questions uh to put
to naomi
and i think you could plumb down a
little bit on a couple of the items
based on my experience of reading
company reports for example on
item nine which is the failure to ensure
financial sustainability i think
possibly within there there is an
investment risk
which i i normally see noted on company
reports
um i suppose as an authority at the
moment we're a kind of fairly low um
risk authority in terms of our
investments approach we don't really
have a lot or any thing in the way of
commercial investments and our treasury
management strategy itself is
kind of very low risk it's all in kind
of bank accounts and um sort of instant
access accounts and that sort of thing
so we don't really have a significant
investment risk in terms of our risk
profile as council obviously if that
were to change that would probably be
something that would need to be noted
more clearly on there on the risk
register but at the moment that's not a
significant i would say in my opinion a
significant risk for the council okay no
ted and the other point is you mentioned
earlier about insurance but
i mean correct me if i'm wrong i didn't
actually see anything in the risk
register about
the adequacy of insurance for
property liabilities and construction
activities
and surely if
there is a failure to maintain adequate
insurance or even renew the insurances
uh god forbid that would be a risk
yeah certainly and i think that's
probably something that's in our
reflected in our service sort of level
risk registers but um i mean that's
almost kind of business as usual for the
council i completely agree that we
should have adequate and appropriate
insurance in place and we and we do
um
but in terms of the strategic kind of
nature of that risk i wouldn't say that
that's probably significant enough to
warrant being on the corporate risk
register
there's nothing particularly that would
give me sort of cause for concern that
there's a risk that we wouldn't be
adequately insured so that's probably
the reason it's not elevated onto the
corporate risk register um but i'd
certainly be expecting that to be
reflected in sort of lower level service
risk registers if that makes sense it
does make sense um i
for what it's worth i think it probably
is worth
making a record of it within
maybe within item nine or a separate
item
okay thank you nate
thank you any further questions ah
councillor milne
um
well it's actually tas naomi um we now
have a slightly new capability now
because we have overview and scrutiny
right and as we move on into 2223
and we've got our new governance
arrangements obviously you probably
welcome
overview proactively looking at that as
it evolves
because then we would then look at it
in retrospect you know towards the end
of the year as part of the work plan
which we could do
because i can see the council's
definitely got a strategy to deal with
things that are slightly out of its
control because you've already aligned
with brentwood
you've already
brought in basildon to help us with the
audit
and all of those things
are areas where
it's not so easy as just planning
something you're totally in control of
and obviously the outside financial
environment so looking at that i'd like
to meet up and perhaps uh with council
wilson
and we can do a more constructive job in
overview secu scrutiny going into 22-23
if that's okay
yeah thank you there but um i think i'd
maybe just take that away and have a
discussion about the most appropriate
forum to to have that um
sort of overall debate i suppose it
depends on what you're looking to
achieve out of this because um obviously
this committee has sort of been tasked
with the
scrutiny if you like of the risk
management arrangements and that's
because it kind of sits more closely
with the actual um sort of overview of
governance arrangements and audits so um
there's nothing to stop this committee
sort of sp um specifically having a more
detailed sort of in-depth review and i
would suggest that this committee is
probably the best forum for that if you
want to have a look at the overarching
kind of risk management arrangements but
certainly where there's individual
programs of work that have risks
attached to them like as you mentioned
the transformation program with
brentwood
i know that those reports are already
scheduled to go into review regularly
and they have already been
and certainly i think that you can have
that discussion about individual
programs of work and the risks
associated with them and then sort of
bring that back i suppose it just
depends what you're actually looking to
try and um
achieve so yeah
it's a simplification perhaps of the
explanation in the preamble to all of
this because there's quite a lot of
material here
i did bring my computer tonight but
thank god you printed it off
um yeah i mean that was
a an issue for councillors to understand
this so you've already started on this
because we've had the understanding
financial statements training so that's
good so that was the area i was looking
at
yeah anyway that's that's my
view thank you and
we have also i know um bazaar and sales
ran some training about the actual role
and function of audit committee and what
um you should expect from members i
think that's something we're looking to
maybe roll out specifically at rochford
and do a bit more training just about
what your individual roles are and as
members of audit committee and what your
sort of duties and remits are so i think
that's maybe something we'll try and
seek to add some member training
schedule for the for the year ahead just
so you've got a clearer idea about what
the responsibilities of the different
committees are if that's helpful
yeah thanks very much thank you
thank you just like to
what naomi said about the training for
basilton um i'm i was available and i
managed to attend the first course that
um was given which was really really
helpful
unfortunately i couldn't attend the
second so if they were both rerun that
would be an advantage for most people
including myself thank you thank you
thank you so much and try and organize
that things yes it's good to have
positive feedback for a training course
so thank you
any further questions
no
right members is the content of the
corporate risk register for
2022-23 noted
thank you members
and this concludes the business of the
meeting the meeting is closed at
2009.
but can i just say thank you to the
it's been very officers
and easily understood so i'd like to
thank the officers and auditors for
doing it thank you
yes perhaps we could still have that in
in the minutes yeah sorry
yes and and um
so i didn't say at the beginning but i
think there are a couple of new faces
that may not be
i don't think i've met paula mills so
welcome and sorry i didn't introduce you
so thank you members we can go